what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today to continue what i can
only describe as the feel good show of
the year squid game episode four stick
to the team the show has been awesome
guys what i'm gonna ask from you is if
you can go ahead and hit that like
button or the dislike button whichever
one as long as you have both that's what
counts democracy just like this show
subscribe click that notification bell
to get notified when our reaction for
the next squid game episode is up full
length watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code or over at our
patreon page cover a whole plethora of
shows over there as well with options
for reaction highlights and watch long
included lastly prepper thank you team
for editing this down you guys rock yeah
let's do it
[Music]
games
no he knows yeah
feeling betrayed
that's right man they're gonna start a
whole new life natural born killers
[Music]
they mix up the food at least dude the
crisp refreshing taste of sprite
they got branded bottles
yeah man
gotta keep that brand alive
excuse me
i can't wait for you to die
i really can't wait man
god i hate this guy so much
you got to be [ __ ] me
what are the rules
they can do whatever they want to each
other i guess
[Applause]
you should just be killing us stick to
the rules
you laid out oh my god wow
[Music]
wow they could just kill each other yep
new rules new game what the hell
oh that is so scary
oh they could just murder each other oh
no
oh he's like i got a new plan
it's weird to watch this show and feel
like now that's not fair yeah
all
right
let's cross a line here buddy
force the rules
see this
i'm a square trigger
yeah boy
my dude
i hope to be just like that square
someday
oh
what what what oh what wow
stick to the team
you bastards
oh thank you god
[Music]
yeah like they're going to sleep
so sadistic
that's me
oh
god
holy crap
oh please kill him
kill him
right in the nuts
[Applause]
how's the old man gonna survive this
i hope he's sound asleep he's just
chilling through this whole thing
[Music]
what the hell
no
god
oh nice work man
on handheld
what are you gonna do
hope it's up to you
my name is squid game
[Music]
i don't know how you would have the
luster to do such an activity right
[Music]
okay
she's gravitated towards like the alpha
personality yeah yeah she's the one who
worms in at his side whoever alpha may
be
harley quinn
he still has battery
what a spool
hey wake up they're trying to kill us
yeah nothing could go wrong today
oh
no
i cannot believe this
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you're going to step through the
stargate this one gonna end on a
cliffhanger
i
i wouldn't put it past with this boy
that would be new i mean for like the
like before the game starts yeah
strength was really important on this
[Music]
one team looks a lot more confident than
the other
oh man
oh my goodness jesus christ
oh my god
no there's chained to the rope too of
course they're chained to the rope
what is she doing
oh she's gonna make a wire to strangle
someone to death
that thread's gonna be the key to
everything
[Applause]
oh my god no
ugh
[Laughter]
oh god diego what a shot
what a shot
if your fall is broken by the pile of
bodies below can you compete in the next
game
[Music]
[Laughter]
this freaking
[Music]
guys
oh boy
they're all taller
all tall dudes
this is why exercise is important
yeah you got to be prepared in case
you're thrown into a game of life and
death doctor that's why a doctor chose
her team
um
the leader did look pretty unconfident
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh wow you can really feel the struggle
[Music]
come on
come on
come on
yes cool
come on oh my god
it's one of them has a trip just one of
them there's one all you need is one
no no
come
[Laughter]
oh on on regain your palace
[Applause]
[Music]
no fair
whoa that was scary yeah oh that was
really scary
god
[Laughter]
yo this is uh this is a good show
this is a great show
i loved loved the way this one was shot
um just brilliantly captured that like
the style they have
really it'd be nice we're only episode
four all right i know those are some of
you guys are like oh just wait jules
wait you guys
it's gonna get crazier i i know i feel
like i can already hear the
thousands of voices
echoing in the ether of you guys saying
that our way
um but right now just from episode four
yes i am loving the way this is shot
right down to that riot scene
um with the way they used full effect of
the strobe effect was wonderfully
wonderfully captured so taut and uh just
like uh immersive
and then here with the with the tug of
war the way they captured that sequence
was
like the the way they like isolate our
figures in in the game with the tug of
war like how everything is just black
and you feel the scale the scope of just
like these tiny figures look how big the
fall is and they drop and just that
desperate angst that they have here you
know you like the clenching of the teeth
and like it it it's just such a like you
physically this is hinging on grip right
and then yet it is gripping your your
heart you can just feel it like just
like the the show just capture holding
your heart just squeezing it
so it's working on this like physical
emotional complementary effect it's so
visceral and palpable i love it so much
just how effective all this is
and then on top of that you just got
like
the the bleak downfall of character
development here because they have it's
not just dark that's what helps balance
it is because you get these like little
shades of
rays of light that that pierce through
the veil once in a while
of you know like the
how some of them are getting to know
each other some of them are forming
teams uh in a genuine way
and and not just a survival of the
fittest way but that theme is like this
is the one that put that at the
forefront you know like this whole
episode has been survival of the fittest
uh it's it's so good it's so damn good
and like you really you really care
about our main team a lot and like the
the main people that we've been focusing
on
of the
you know oh my god i'm such an [ __ ]
you know when that next next episode
we're going to pull up all the games
that we're going to commit to memory
yeah we got to do it uh but yeah the
main characters and even the pickpocket
girl um yes like that you really care
about them and then they've done such an
interesting job at drawing and i promise
i'm going to let you talk a second
they've done such an interesting job at
drawing this line where
the enemy are the people who have like
thrust them into the position
look what we got here oh getting into
your food get into your food we got a
cat thing we've got a cat that's the
next game
make sure john closes his back
it's closed he's trying to go inside
there's nothing in there what this is
not closed there's nothing in that this
is
trying to get look at that he's trying
to get food in the other pocket that is
all zombies he will succeed and he's
trying to excavate into the bag i'm like
dude just give it up give it up bro it's
hair through um yes uh so
[Music]
what they've done a good job of doing is
drawing this para this
this line of
because these people have chosen to be
here
the sadistic rich people who have put
these
desperate
individuals in this game
are not
even
the bad guys
but the betty bad guys are the [ __ ]
gang on the team and it's so fascinating
because it's like the real enemy
is
technically this these sadists who are
doing this game yet
no they're not
yeah because the people have chosen to
be here no exactly or or yeah or have
kind of looked at their position and
looked at what's available to them and
gone i have really no other viable
option than to be here and i think
it's it's great because this show has
done a really nice job of developing its
own shadowy
underworld organization with of which we
still don't know the true nature and yet
it also still feels perfectly aligned
with this socio-economic class metaphor
because it is
you know who is really behind the
curtain pulling the strings and what are
the rules of the game actually and it's
like yeah you look at this and in a
sense you're like well hey it's the
people who are now kind of yeah rising
to a new level of villainy and realizing
that they can take each other out in
order to improve the game but even that
is just a symptom of what it's been
thrust upon them by the people who are
orchestrating and pulling all the
strings of this and who are rigging it
in a way where it's not actually fair
for anybody and so yeah it's like you
know you can look at the ways in which
different socioeconomic systems again
set you up and i thought of the last
episode too with the whole way that
they're like you know we gave you all
the rules and tools that you need to win
and all you got to do is play by the
rules and win and you'll be fine and
it's not as simple as that and the
system incentivize i love that detail
here about how like yeah we we
intentionally didn't give you enough
food to create this competition to
create these circumstances under which
you guys are going to get more and more
desperate and more and more cutthroat
and it's interesting to watch as
everybody you know looks back and forth
and thinks okay what's going to matter
the most under this paradigm and it's
like it is this perfect high concept
surreal survival horror game show but
every level of it i feel like you can
compare and contrast with
just you know the rat race of being in
these
money systems yeah well the show is
brilliant in its conception because they
have these games that are so simple
because they're child they're children's
games they're just putting it on a large
scale so it's easy to understand the
games and what you have to do it's not
like
other shows that will do like these
crazy advances we've seen like survival
reality based you know like hunger games
running man
we've seen them and oftentimes it can be
a little bit complex in the rules or
it's just a straightforward just kill
each other yeah so here they have these
elaborate set pieces that are easy to
comprehend due to the nature of where
they stem from you know so i think that
is so smart like it's just such a smart
concept
and um
what i especially loved here is the
development of the the elderly man i
feel like there's just something here
that we're not
being told about him um or he's gonna i
hope he i hope he makes it to the final
the the the finish line i hope he makes
it again because i thought it was great
how the first half of this he's just
viewed he's like scared sad weak
uh
incapable of defending off you know and
people who might try to kill him so he
cowers through the top and pleads like
don't stop i'm scared
he's afraid he's gonna die and he can't
remember his own name and then even when
they're forming their team they've got
an elderly man he can't even recruit a
guy you know and then in the final
moments of the game he's like no i i i
there's a strategy to this and we could
do this with a proper strategy which i
was like oh [ __ ] he's still he's the
hope
that's so cool it's cool it's really
good like as freaking harrowing and dark
as this [ __ ] is with like these little
touches of like guy falls down and then
of course of course one of these guys
still alive and then you know like the
way they beat each other to a pulp there
during the riot and uh
and then like i'm here with my wife like
jesus christ
broke my heart like sorry i can't choose
you because we could only want men and
we're gonna choose one sorry
oh my god radically speaking but that's
and that's the thing is like those are
the positions that you get pushed into
when you're in a rat race money game not
to say that there's a one-to-one
comparison but yeah i mean you know on
the one hand you're like who deserves to
have a good solid team around them
probably the married couple or the
elderly man and yet in the cutthroat
nature of the game that we have been
presented with and the rules that were
kind of helpless but to follow
yeah those people get screwed yeah dude
this this this show is uh it's awesome
it's it's it just keeps getting better
and
and more surprising and uh that like the
the the way they
develop the characters along the way is
so fascinating to watch and uh and then
we got the detective guy who i'm like
man i don't know how this guy's staying
level-headed during all this i'd be so
sick
yeah absolutely and i i love that
they've kept that going and i'm curious
to see obviously where that's gonna go
for the plot but i just love how much
they've made out of this one character
and we only see his face like once in a
while he's always silent he's always
just body language and yet they managed
to make him stand out and they also
managed to create this sense that like
yes he is sort of growing and realizing
what he needs to do to blend in further
and further into this and yeah just each
episode there they've thus far been
really great at knowing how much time to
spend with each situation so that you
really feel like you're in the midst of
it and you're sort of trapped there with
everybody and each episode too they're
great at throwing in a visual or a
stylistic flourish that really
it's always just like one or two little
things that bring that tension that much
higher in this episode yeah it's just
that beautiful application of the strobe
to make the whole thing a torture
nightmare yeah man oh brilliant yeah
brilliant stuff i'm really loving this
man this is brilliant all right guys
what'd you think about this episode uh
hit that like button please and
subscribe
[ __ ] we got more to go and hey let's do
a
deontay w tung punch fart box that's
right that's his name and if there's
anyone here who could easily survive a
riot situation
such as this it's got to be w tongue
punch fart box think about his
specialties
you know punch and punch and fart boxes
imagine going around they're doing all
that look at how many alliances you
could form man look at how many
interestingly intimate and awkward
bathroom exchanges you could have with
your unique gift ruthless lethal my god
no one will mess with the menace that is
you they just want to get near you out
of discomfort it's not protect your
cheeks deontay's around you never know
what he's going to punch next with his
tongue
oh guys you fart on us god no no
big part people can handle violence when
people don't like just icky they don't
like being converted
so uh tongue punch man good luck out
there you might survive the squid games
[Music]
you